some of the reactions from within the
Saints locker room although as of right
now there is no locker room to gather in
because of the pandemic which I think in
a roundabout way helps and you know what
if they were having offseason workouts
throughout now yeah what happened
yesterday may not have occurred who
knows but Emmanuel Sanders s mhm
ignorant his reaction to what drew brees
said yesterday Alvin Kamara OOP
was his comment and Cameron Jordan be a
better Ally that was just the start of
it and that was all before Malcolm
Jenkins made his comments Chris and then
later in the day
Marcus Davenport who is a fairly young
still member of the team a first-round
draft pick a couple of years ago he
posted a tweet defending drew Brees and
cam Jordan basically said hey Marcus
you're entitled to your opinion but this
ain't it what Davenport said was drew
wasn't talking about the current
protests the riots are really anything
besides his feelings on kneeling during
the national anthem he even explained
what they were the basis and he actually
stands with us do we have to entirely
agree with him no and again Cameron
Jordan's reaction was this saying it
does it seemingly denounced the focal
point of what the intended kneeling was
meant for yes that gets back to the
point we made earlier the message was
lost in this effort to say you're
disrespecting the flag you're
disrespecting the military you're
disrespecting the country no matter how
many times Colin Kaepernick or anyone
else including us said no he's not
people didn't want to hear it so I think
that's where it went off the rails
yesterday for Drew Brees to bring back
that deflection technique that we used
in 2016 to justify not taking seriously
what Colin Kaepernick right what is my
and not ever really hitting head on the
issue of what was going on you know even
in the Instagram comment hey that was it
was motivational it was nice and some of
the things he says on the Yahoo Finance
interview yeah they're nice I understand
that but of course at the end it was
very insensitive answering that final
that final comment and then you know
never really addressing the issue itself
and taking hit head on and saying what
was wrong about that and then going on
the course the tirade about
his grandfather's being in the world war
two and all that where I would want to
say to like drew you are you sure your
grandfather's would be that happy right
now if they saw the state of America and
how african-americans are treated on a
daily basis in our country you know I
don't know I had a grandfather the
fought in World War two I'd like to
think that he wouldn't be happy with the
way things are right now either
and it is a peaceful protest so yeah
that's where it all went wrong and sorry
to cut you off I didn't mean to do that
no no no no it's fine I mean look I I
want us to have the back and forth I
mean look I I don't know where the
saints go from here and Sean Payton who
we both have a ton of respect for he's
got a challenge now he's got to figure
out how to fix this and I don't know
that it necessarily falls on him I think
some in the locker room would say Drew's
got to fix it Drew's got to do something
no Dan we're gonna talk later we're
gonna talk later about Vic Fangio the
Broncos coach he said something on
Tuesday
the Drule reaction and he quickly came
out and said I was wrong to say what I
said and we'll go into those details
later in the program but I think that
that the challenge now for Drew Brees is
what is he going to do to try to fix
this I think the comments that were made
to Mike Triplett espn.com yesterday were
an effort to maybe begin the process of
putting toothpaste back in the tube but
not nearly enough I think anything other
than I was wrong and uh and again I
don't want to speak for Drew Brees but
he I think he's got to do something big
at this point and it's got to be
believable to those in the locker room
doesn't matter what the rest of us think
it's got to be believable to his
teammates that this is something he is
doing and saying not simply to put out a
fire that he started but because it
shows the true feelings that he has for
what his teammates are going through and
it's not going to be easy because let me
tell you the clock is ticking loudly and
with each passing hour it's going to be
harder and harder for Drew Brees to find
a way to fix this and and it's gonna be
harder and harder for Sean Payton to
find a way to fix it if Drew Brees
doesn't fix it before Peyton tries to
pull everyone together and move forward
yeah I agree I mean I think you know the
drew Brees
I don't think he has any choice but to
just take this head-on
and you're right admit you know wrong
and what he said and then try to
continue and push the conversation into
a good spot to join the the good fight
for what you know everybody in the
National Football League is fighting for
it which is you know equality and
justice in our country for everybody so
that's where you know I think he's gonna
have to do that and it's not gonna be
easy
certainly and I think so people are
gonna be pissed off of them no doubt
about that it's there but but I do think
he's got to come out strong and just
take this head-on
he can't say you know Malcolm Jenkins
called them out you know drew didn't
want to have the conversation in a
public forum Malcolm Jenkins let that be
known there at the end of that comment
when I think drew right now is in the
corner of where hey drew I would advise
you to take it head-on and admit you
were wrong and deal with those issues
and that's gonna be the first phase of
trying to heal the locker room because
you're right Mike I mean locker room
ain't gonna be the same there's no doubt
about it you know you don't build this
respect and you know politeness and
things like that okay all of that but
they're gonna be looking at the corner
out of the corner of their eye at Drew
Brees and looking at him in a different
way
and then when they're in the huddle and
at certain situations they're gonna be
looking at him going uh I don't know
about this guy is he really in this with
us or is this just about him you know
there's gonna be dots that are gonna
creep through guys heads so there's
gonna be a lot of healing there's gonna
have to be team meeting Sean Payton's
gonna have to lead the way and lead the
charge here but Drew Brees I do think
his best way to approach this is take it
head-on take your lumps you made a
mistake and show that you're sorry for
it and then try to mend the wounds
you've created in the african-american
community and all those that are you
know involved in this fight all together
and here's how jarring the reaction has
been Chris we haven't even mentioned
that LeBron James took on the the issue
and took issue directly with Drew Brees
and and his decision to rely upon his
own grandfather's experiences when the
reality is grandfathers of
african-american men fought for the
country and they came home to anything
but a hero's welcome as Malcolm Jenko
so this thing has really taken off and
it's gonna be one hell of a challenge
for drew brees to put the toothpaste
back in the tube first of all he has to
want to do it it has to be real it has
to be genuine you know if he doesn't
want to do it if he is going to retreat
to his corner and fold his arms and say
everyone else is wrong and I'm right and
and shame on them for not understanding
my point and I don't owe anyone an
obligation I've I have lived a life of
service to others I mean it would be
very easy for him to say I'm not doing
this I'm not gonna give in I shouldn't
have to give in I don't know that's
gonna fix things I think he has to do
something and here's another example of
why he should strongly consider what he
can do I mean it would have been
unthinkable yesterday at this time to
hear that at a protest in New Orleans
there was a profane chant directed to
Drew Brees who why the guy gave five
million dollars to cover 19 relief he's
been one of the people who was directly
responsible for rebuilding New Orleans
in the aftermath of Katrina the guy has
done great things for his community
which just shows you how quickly can all
be squandered because there was last
night a profane three word chant and the
last two words were drew Brees and the
first word is one that we cannot say it
broke out it wasn't it wasn't an
overwhelming chant but somebody from the
New Orleans times-picayune and captured
it on video it was enough people that
you heard it and it lasted five or six
seconds and I about fell out of my chair
and it just shows you how quickly in a
moment like this when there is no middle
ground you can't carve out a middle
ground here
you can't keep everyone happy here and
that may be what he was autumn utley
trying to do right you have to pick a
side on this right we said this
yesterday
you're either in favor of equal
treatment for all and against racism in
all forms as chaud console eloquently
put it you're either in that camp or
you're not if you're anywhere else
you're not in that camp it is as clear
as it can be
you're either fully in support of all
Americans of all humans being treated
with equality and justice and respect
and all the ideals that we see
here in the anthem in the Declaration of
Independence and the Constitution and
all of our founding documents either we
are in favor of that and believe that
for everyone or we don't
yeah that's simple and when you try
Chris and this gets to the point you
were making if there is a little bit of
a of a of a political effort here to
keep everyone happy and not make anyone
upset well you know what the only way
that you're going to avoid upsetting
anyone at a time like this is to say
nothing at all is to not even do the
interview is to not speak because you
either have to be all in if you're not
all in on this movement you're all out
and I think that's what happened
yesterday you don't try to both sides
something like this you're either with
it or if you're not with it those who
are with it are going to look at you and
say you're against it yeah well you know
as we see here I mean drew brees is
until yesterday basically got into
Orleans so that just tells you how
passionate the subject is to people in
our country and how it hits home and
really cuts into people's skin when we
have you know unarmed innocent African
American people constantly being shown
excessive force by the police and then
of course sometimes murdering them so it
is a sensitive subject and drew brees
echoed comments that you know of course
the other side used to basically bring
down the conversation of police
brutality and squash that so you know
and within that at that time of course
you know the players that were kneeling
we're be calling because we're being
called sons of [ __ ] and bastards
right and then we saw that at the same
time we saw people with confederate and
Nazi flags being called very nice people
like they were better Americans why cuz
they stand for the anthem I mean I think
they break 50 laws a day and they're
anti-american and they should like they
shouldn't even be able to call
themselves American in this country with
some of that actions so breeze echoes
those talking points and of course that
inflames you know reaction
from african-american people and people
like you would me because we look at
that as completely wrong which it is and
that's the issue there and you know drew
brees who's done a lot of good things in
his life I know that I mean he really
has he's done a lot for New Orleans the
country in a lot of ways but he lost his
way on this subject right here and he
was insensitive yesterday and yeah he's
gonna have to do some building back of
trust with people and of course some
team building here in the recent future
and again time it's not it's not of the
essence it is the essence it's it's you
could argue it's already too late yeah
I'm serious serious gonna be hard yeah
the intensity of this moment something
unlike anything I've ever experienced in
almost 55 years of life right tent to
come off in a way that your co-workers
your colleagues your friends your
brothers in arms would regard as
tone-deaf in a moment like this is
something that is going to be very hard
to fix and if you're going to fix it
right you got to fix it immediately you
can't sit back and assess the damage
you can't put surrogates out there to
take up for you and defend you and hope
that'll turn the page you've got to come
up with a way to fix it yourself and you
have to understand that that there's no
way to fix it without getting your hands
even dirtier than maybe they already are
or maybe maybe taking the chunk out of
your pride I mean look at this is a
moment to set pride aside if you truly
want to fix this this is a moment to set
pride aside and and admit the mistake
loudly and plainly and and convey it's
got to be convincing it can't come off
as contrived or just to end see that's
the problem Chris the longer it takes
the more is people drive like yeah the
more it's gonna look like it's not real
that it's a calculated effort to clean
up a mess and again I again look I'm
trying to be I'm trying to be fair to
the story but I'm trying to be fair to
reality here too and I think in this
moment any sort of delay is gonna make
it exponentially harder for drew brees
to get this right with his teammates
mic when you saw this just you know your
first you know what was your first like
football thought like the first thing I
thought of you know and again maybe
it'll be the exact opposite but I
literally the first thing I thought of
of course after getting through like wow
that was insensitive and I can't believe
you said that all those things well then
I did think about the locker room and
the New Orleans Saints football team and
that I almost immediately my brain went
well there goes the Superbowl for the
Saints I don't know what they can do it
now now listen maybe it can be the
opposite effect where it could bring the
team together eventually and they can
all you know use it as something to jump
off on in a positive way and and and do
that but you know initially I went wow
this is going to be really hard to
overcome for this Saints team who's been
through a lot already and it's talented
it in that Super Bowl window I just it
makes me question whether you could
weather this type of storm for a full
football season I mean my first thought
was wow Drew's gonna have some
explaining to do behind the scenes to
his teammates about this because they're
not gonna want to hear a repeat of the
the phrases that were used to ignore
Colin Kaepernick's message in 2016 to
allow people made uncomfortable by what
Colin Kaepernick was trying to say to
utter that phrase so they could ignore
it that that's bringing back an old
wound and it's not gonna be helpful but
I thought it would all happen behind the
scenes what was jarring to me was the
public nature of the reaction which
shows you how strong and powerful this
moment is you know the old ways of doing
things of handling these things
discreetly and behind the scenes and not
airing out dirty laundry in this moment
that doesn't work in this moment the
dirty laundry's getting aired out right
and that that may be the only way to
properly advance the discussion and get
people to take a hard look at things
that they've said and things that
they've done that maybe they need to
reconsider
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports